are these two situations equivalent on
the left you're sitting on the earth on
the right you're inside an accelerating
rocket either way you feel your body
pushing against the floor as if there's
gravity it's impossible for you to tell
the difference or is
it hey crazies what we're talking about
here is something called the equivalence
principle if you're accelerating
uniformly any measurements you take will
be physically equivalent to measurements
taken in a uniform gravitational field
of appropriate strength it's one of the
founding principles of general
relativity but is it true and if it's
not does that make relativity invalid
we'll come back to both of these
questions a little later for now I just
want you to imagine you've woken up
locked in a room this room has no
windows you hear no sound you don't feel
any vibrations you're completely
isolated from the world outside this is
exactly the situation I've put one of my
Expendable clones in great here we go
again this is going to be hilarious
where do you think you are man well I
can't tell exactly but I feel my weight
against the floor so I'm going to guess
this room is somewhere on Earth
interesting interesting what if I told
you you weren't on earth oh so I'm on
another planet with the same gravity
nope you're inside a rocket accelerating
at exactly 9.8 m/s squared weird I can't
tell the difference that's exactly the
point the 9.8 me m/s squared is what we
call the acceleration due to gravity on
Earth at least it's a gain of 9.8 m/s
for every second of travel for some
perspective 9.8 m/s is about 22 mph or
35 km hour without air resistance that's
how much a falling object speeds up
every second for expendable clone to
feel his weight against the floor his
rocket must share that acceleration it's
accelerating through deep space at the
same rate that Things Fall toward Earth
what most of us call weight is just the
feeling of weight not the weight itself
right now you're feeling it upward push
from the ground or your chair or both
you also have a weight pulling you down
something you never feel sure that
upward push only exists because the
Earth is already pulling you down with
gravity but what if there was another
reason for that upward push like a
rocket you happen to be inside
accelerating forward you would feel a
weight even though you don't have one
but just because one situation is
indistinguishable from another that
doesn't necessarily make them equivalent
there may be an upward push in both
situations but only one has a weight
right we're not saying his contact with
the floor is gravity are we the
equivalence principle seems to say so
but that's kind of sus and a huge part
of science is tearing ideas to shreds
for the benefit of all humankind
whatever survives is the truth or or at
least approximately the truth so let's
see if we can find an exception to this
rule what if we bring in another object
say a squirrel from the comfort of our
space station we see a squirrel floating
stationary in space as the rocket
accelerates upward the squirrel slips
through a hole and into the rocket from
Expendable clones point of view it would
be as if a squirrel fell from the sky
into his room it's a perfectly
reasonable conclusion not only does the
squirrel fall but it falls in exactly
the same way that it would if it were
falling on Earth it's as if there's a
gravity on the squirrel even though we
know there's no source of gravity nearby
the equivalence principle still seems to
hold up H what if we have the squirrel
come in from the side instead let's say
the squirrel is moving in a straight
line sideways as the rocket accelerates
upward the squirrel slips through a hole
in the side of the rocket Expendable
clone will see the squirrel enter his
room from the wall and then fall to the
floor in an arc as if there was gravity
if we could see inside his room we'd see
the squirrel still moving in a straight
line it would be the floor accelerating
upward but according to my clone it's
the squirrel that accelerates downward
like a projectile to him it looks like
there's Gravity the equivalence
principle still holds I think it's time
for something a little more extreme
let's say his rocket is like 20 miles
long and he's running up the stairs
every 10 floors or so he stops to
measure his weight with a bathroom scale
no matter what floor he's on his weight
will always be the same that wouldn't be
true with a 20 M tall building in that
case your weight weight would gradually
decrease as you went up floors your
weight on the top floor would be 1% less
than your weight on the bottom floor
bingo bango equivalence principle broken
wait a minute that's not a uniform
gravitational field ah crap this
principle does require that gravity be
uniform and that's only approximately
true near the surface of the Earth if
you get far enough away we stop being
able to make that approximation not only
does gravity get weaker with distance it
can also turn down is toward the center
of the the Earth which isn't always the
same direction Earth is round and
sometimes we have to account for that
really long bridges are a good example
if we were to drop two squirrels a mile
apart and from a mile high they'd be 1.3
ft or 40 cm closer together by the time
they hit the ground which is yet another
situation where the equivalence
principle does not apply if the
accelerating rocket was a 1 M Cube the
two squirrels would stay exactly one
mile apart the entire fall the
equivalence principle only Compares
uniform acceleration with uniform
gravitational fields but it was never
meant to be a universal law its purpose
is to help us design thought experiments
so we can ask the right questions the
experiments in this video seem to
suggest that gravity is simply
acceleration we can't see since they
only happen in our minds they can't tell
us if that conclusion is true but if it
is true it can tell us what consequences
we might see remember when we had a
squirrel enter Expendable clones room
through a wall well what would happen if
a pulse of light entered the room
instead it would also Bend toward the
floor like the squirrel's path did just
not nearly as much the bend would be
subtle because light is fast fast fast
if we believe the equivalence principle
and we haven't found any reason not to
then that means light should be affected
by gravity just like squirrels which
seems absolutely Bonkers there's a
reason people didn't believe Einstein
and Hilbert when they published this in
1950 they had to actually prove it which
means they had to wait for a toal solar
eclipse and for World War I to end
Europe was leading science at the time
and they were understandably kind of a
mess anyway the idea is that if light
from a star passes close enough to the
sun on its way to Earth then the sun
will bend its path making it appear in a
slightly different location in the sky
and I mean slightly they estimated the
deflection angle to be less than two Ark
seconds that's less than 1800th of a
degree the US tried to do the experiment
in in June of 1918 in Baker City Oregon
that was near the end of the war but
alas it was cloudy with 100% chance of
failure the next total solar eclipse
wouldn't happen until May of 1919
European scientists planned out two
Expeditions one for saal Brazil and
South America and the other for Principe
in Africa The Hope was that at least one
of them would get decent images and
after some technical difficulties both
teams Managed IT here's one of the
images from Brazil the results of this
experiment confirmed that prediction
from general relativity light is in fact
affected by gravity just like squirrels
as far as we can tell gravity is just
acceleration we can't see the
equivalence principle might not apply to
solar eclipses but it did present us
with a thought experiment which led us
to conduct a real one a real experiment
we never would have thought to do
otherwise so is the equivalence
principle true yes is it Universal no
but that doesn't mean it hasn't been
extremely useful and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
let's talk about nebula a different kind
of streaming service different because
it's owned and run by us the creators on
the platform tons of creators like me
put our regular content there completely
add and sponsor free there's also a long
list of exclusive content you won't find
anywhere else on the internet want to
watch a featur length analysis on how
they adapted Lord of the Rings into the
best Trilogy ever made there's a nebula
original from Lindsay Ellis want to see
a multi-part series exploring the
history of human evolution check out
becoming Human by real science they even
have nebula classes like what is Code by
coding train where you can begin to
learn a skill that's becoming more
necessary as time goes on I know I know
you're probably thinking that you don't
want another streaming service I I get
that and frankly I'm a bit biased
because I'm onet platform but I feel
like it's great because it's what I
actually watch and they're not charging
an arm and a leg either
using my link to sign up will get you
40% off the annual plan but also nebula
is currently offering lifetime
memberships for a limited time you pay
once and get access for your entire life
it's kind of revolutionary but if you're
interested in any of the streaming plan
sign up using our link it really helps
out the
channel many of you pointed out that we
needed the distance to the Sun to use
stellar parallax and that's true
thankfully we found that on 166 years
before we used Parallax on other stars
but that's a topic for another day
anyway thanks for
watching